tasha is in deep uh she has unbelievably
strong feelings she is falling in love
but is that going to be reciprocated
fully in the way she wants it to be and
maybe those scenes are telling
and how this ends up is there a proposal
gone wrong
we're about to wait and find out but i
will just say this it is
incredibly emotional
who better to talk about all things
bachelor nation then
mr chris harrison himself oh mr harrison
we have many questions
um first i want to get this out of the
way we've seen
lots of intense discussions this season
on the bachelorette uh talk about
eating disorders and uh suicide and
race all of these really big topics and
we kind of wanted to know how production
handles
all that have you guys uh discussed with
some of these contestants
what they would be talking about
beforehand afterwards
how do you guys address all that you
know going into a season we really
encourage
all the contestants to really bear their
soul and and just go with
what they feel and if it is black lives
matter if it is
ben and going through his mental health
um we embrace it
and and we encourage that we we want
those conversations
um you know i think the bachelor of
bachelorette
is always a sign of the times not vice
versa i don't think we
you know wag the dog the dog wags the
tail and so
you know i think we're a microcosm of
what's going on out there and obviously
black lives matter
and and racial injustices and where that
stands as a is a huge
topic as is mental health and what is
happening in the world right now and
suicide rates are up 200
and so these are topics that are
affecting everybody in the world right
now so yeah it
it should bleed into the pages of the
bachelor and bachelorette and and so we
encourage that
there have been discussions before i i
don't think it's a secret that you guys
have a therapist who works with the
contestants so how did that therapist
play in
when there were a lot of these tough
topics no more than usual
they're always there and you're right
you know you get tested into the show
we do have um medical and and mental
uh help there 24 7.
should anybody need it um and and they
often do
um in a lot of aspects and they are
available after the show
is over if you need to lean on somebody
we're always very careful and
we really do try to take care of
everybody on the show uh on camera and
off camera but um you know it really
wasn't any different there was
you know take ben for example that we
just watched that
incredibly compelling conversation when
he
bared his soul to tasha i guess we can
go deep um
i uh i had two failed suicide attempts
in 2018 2019 um
you know and i don't mean to like throw
that on you it's like a weird
thing to do here um it was kind of
cathartic i i've talked to him in the
last
few days and it really meant a lot to
him that we gave him that stage
and he's he was embraced in that way um
is it something that you or tasha had
any idea he
would get into did you guys kind of do a
touch base with everybody after that
oftentimes we know the story we know the
backstory
or we know that there is something um
underneath
will they always go there no and so we
don't know you know we encourage them to
to talk about whatever they
want but you know i know people give us
as producers all this credit for
making people do things or telling them
you can't make somebody bear their soul
like that
either ben is going to feel comfortable
in that space and give that to tasha or
he's not
either zach is going to come clean and
talk about his substance abuse and
addiction or he's not
um that that is in the moment and so you
can't
force that on anybody but um i i like
the show better i think it's more
sincere more real
more uh more relatable when these real
human beings who seem like they're
perfect on the outside
are not perfect you know we all have
that in our life i think it's great for
people to see that
well i think it's evident of how deep
tasha's connections with these remaining
guys are
what can you tease about the final
episodes how is this all gonna end
um first of all they start stacking up
from here on out we're kind of backed up
uh to christmas
uh obviously we're a little bit off off
kilter and off our schedule
so the next two weeks everybody needs to
know they are back to back monday and
tuesday night episodes
so you know get your drinks and your
rows say ready
for those next two weeks but you're
right lauren things have definitely
kicked up a notch in the intimacy
department
um the the hometown dates are a little
bit different obviously we have to bring
home to laquinta so it is a very
different vulnerable side because
you know families feel comfortable with
home court advantage they don't have
that these are
these are moms and dads and friends that
aren't used to stepping onto our stage
and so it was a very vulnerable
almost uncomfortable feeling because
they were walking into the lights the
cameras in
our moment so it's a very different
hometowns than you've ever seen before
and it's only going to get more
difficult more emotional as we go on
good evening bennett walks in like you
never left
you guys look like you've seen a ghost
i'm scared to death i'm nervous as hell
i don't want to hurt anyone like this
is really real for me i don't see him
coming back
well promos show tasha crying on the
side of the road then she's crying
in a white dress in what looks like a
proposal moment
so what happens in each of those
breakdowns just as much as the guys are
into this
tasha is in deep she has unbelievably
strong feelings she is falling in love
but is that going to be reciprocated
fully in the way she wants it to be and
maybe those scenes are telling
in how this ends up is there a proposal
gone wrong
we're about to wait and find out but i
will just say this it is
incredibly emotional i don't like seeing
tasha cry in that white dress it scares
me
well it's a side of tasha honestly
lauren that we don't really get
to see very often she is this kind of i
don't want to say perfect
to put her on a pedestal but she's this
bubbly gorgeous
you know woman that we always just kind
of see in this certain light
so when you see her vulnerable when you
see her broken hearted and you see her
at that level it is it's just different
it really does hit you in a different
way
yeah it's heartbreaking chris harrison
we don't like to see taisha cry
you release matt james as women give me
a couple women to watch for here i
noticed we have
a socialite and is that a queen on the
season of the bachelor
you're talking about kit uh our social
life i think uh and you're gonna love
this think carrie bradshaw sex in the
city her mom is a
very very well to do very well-known
um fashion designer and so she is very
sex in the city very care of bradshaw
you're gonna love kid
um you're talking about queen victoria
right um queen victoria is here
and uh she's here to rule i don't know
if you're gonna love her
her judgments but you're definitely
going to appreciate
queen victoria and then on the other
side you have some amazing women uh you
know kind of like
tasha and claire's season we have an
unbelievable group of women
bree uh is is a woman who left an
unbelievably high-paying tech
job i can't say the company because i
don't want to ruin it but she kind of
like ali fedotowsky left an amazing job
to come find love with matt james you
have a girl like sarah who i don't want
to ruin her story
but she is the caretaker of her family
and she's finally doing something for
herself and here to find love
there was such a response to matt james
being the bachelor the biggest response
we've ever had
and we wanted to give as many women a
chance to find love as possible so
we start with 32 but there will be more
than those that arrive and i can also
give you this nugget
one woman who arrives is a very very
familiar face to vaccinations
cheers to fallen in love you've never
been in love i haven't
my job is to change that well you say in
the bachelor promo
that it is your job to help matt fall in
love matt says he never has
so are you successful yeah you know it's
not that he's never
been in love i think with matt it's he
didn't realize until he was the bachelor
that the words he was saying didn't have
the meaning that he wanted them to have
he said i love you before he thought he
would have been in love but
when you dive into this it really does
strip you down
um not to pat ourselves on the back but
it really takes you to places in your
emotions you've never been before and i
think matt realized wow i really have
never felt this before
so it is a wild ride and if i do my job
correctly
i will fix it do i we'll see
i will say this about matt's journey and
getting to know him
you all see a certain side of him on
social media there is
so much more you're seeing the five
percent of the iceberg there is so much
depth there is so
many layers to this man that you're
gonna get to know um good and bad i mean
there's just stuff in his past in his
family that you know like we all do
we have baggage that has made us who we
are there is baggage that has made matt
the man he is
um and he's a great man but there are
things that he's going to have to get
past some hurdles he will have to clear
before he can
find that happily ever after have you
found a bachelorette among matt's 32
women
we have not officially found a
bachelorette at all there are women on
this show that will definitely be
contenders everyone will fall i'm good
i'm good
for our new just keeps getting hotter
bachelor any other filming updates is
bachelor in paradise gonna happen what's
going on
nothing official obviously we're in a
holding pattern like everybody else
waiting for this vaccine and hopefully
knock on wood this vaccine will change
our lives
as a country much less as a production
our goal what we have on the calendar
right now is go back into the
bachelorette like normal
that will lead us into bachelor in
paradise like normal
will the world be normal who knows
we will see but if the vaccine comes
through which it should
mid spring it should allow us to get
back in
in proper order
[Music]
you